déplacer comment l'aide n'est ce pas
très bien voilà pas de dommages
ou le cas si c'est vrai que depuis deux
semaines du tc bat par la fiction de
l'ader battre par la fiction de la deux
je sais pas tu sais pas non chômage et
du salon journal aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est une bonne fiction je ne sais pas
je regarde pas les fictions de la zone
ouest parce que c'est une bonne fiche je
la regarderai bien moi ouais je sais pas
si c'est une fiction interne c'est une
friction que l'on a entre
artificiellement de chatou d'entretenir
être certain a dit m quand j'ai débarqué
dans télé 7 jours balises animateurs ils
sont copains sur la une puisque ce bâti
la paix sa fille margot comme la sienne
d'ailleurs si jean sienne je
l'appellerai statham ben voilà comme ça
pourquoi il a un chien crépel devra
cependant lancé drucker qui passe ou
alors quelle morale soutien de
l'expérience pour charger l'udc mais
très bien six mois maintenant des
studios chinois qui joue de la chapelle
à bari quelle morale qui tient l'est il
n'y a pas de morale dans ce métier il
n'y a pas de ces loisirs qui la morale
la règle absolue c'est surtout ne pas
avoir de morts de morale à recevoir du
talent ouais ça se passe si en général
non souffre depuis deux semaines ce que
je voulais dire monsieur pas besoin
monsieur pas tu ne la prendrait il
faudra que tu as comme non c'était dans
télé 7 jours si ses ventes et l'essai de
jouer oui
je crois qu'en ce moment on est en train
en période électorale de tremblay
de rumeurs de sondages l'écho et c'est
l'argent qui pourrait qui sait tout ça
mais on est en grandes périodes de son
domaine ni les uns ni les autres suppute
évidence à la télévision dans la cadre
là parlant de sa carrière de chanteur à
la
voix en parler est ce que ta carrière de
chanteur a souffert de du fait que tu
présente une émission la télévision je
te dirai seulement quelques années dans
quelques mois voire quelques mois mais
ce que tu as vendu autant de temps
dernier disque de femme que j'aime ou de
papa son père par exemple
mon dernier run rd 45 tours
je souhaite en a vendu autant que les
deux comtés de près c'est normal c'était
pas les deux précédents partis
à trois ans et 5e assises mais entre
temps j'ai fait d'autres disques qui se
suit plus ou moins vendues
là je peux te d'affirmer que des barthes
et moite une chanson qui ce sera plutôt
bien il m'étonnerait qu'on va voir
annonce assez retors innocent par une
pile de relâche depuis imprimeur là tu
vois jouer je connais pas on connaît pas
encore la carrière de celle ci au total
10 restants dans quelques mois très bien
est ce que tu as été
choqués par mais on vient du tout parce
que nous y avait quand même présenté à
une passe et ce qui était marqué mes
journaux a les poches de sang est celui
qu'il avait présenté un ring c'est toi
qui avais dit ça tout à fait je
comprends et a été choqué par la façon
d'en
ont ils l'ont un peu viré quand même là
sur tf1 mais
je pars on avait l'impression que morose
y avait une chaîne à ses pieds il a
découvert des tags ou qu'il avait un
boulet ouais il est bien
il a droit et retour de détention il n'a
pas de soucis à ce faire thierry paulin
non tu l'a pas aidé quand même tapas et
des grandes déclarations dans la presse
pour dire c'était pas très bien la façon
dont il avait prêté
non ce que j'ai appris qu'ils vous
disent séparé du trésor est
gelée immédiatement appelé
il est un ami et
maintenant c'est le sentiment que j'ai
fait ce qu'il m'a très comprends que ça
l'arrangeait ce qui va se dire
maintenant d'autres ambitions et il a eu
du mal à séparer qu'on a du mal à
séparer d'une
femme objet ou d'une chose comme ça y va
des 10 ans d'expérience sur le 13 heures
il avait envie de faire d'autres choses
qu'il avait très bien réussi entre temps
à des missions spéciales je crois qu'il
aime ça et je trouve que c'est très bien
ce qui lui arrive à faire ça va
régénérer chez lui
d'autres choses comme merveilleux 30 il
a bien fait d'accepter
de donner le bébé est quelqu'un que je
ressens alors tf1 quand même fait dire
quand il avait plus personne la ouate
mois de septembre ils sont venus
chercher moi j'ai toujours pensé que ça
allait marcher est ce que je pense que
tu as la fête à la pêche était appris et
sabatier car dan huss et maintenant ils
sont ils se conduisent un peu comme des
pingouins parce qu'au départ il fait
venir une fois par mois maintenant il
vient deux fois par mois et dix qu'à la
rentrée va être là tout le temps est ce
que tu penses pas qu'il se produise un
peu comme d un braque moi je pense
qu'ils se conduisent comme une chaîne
commerciale doit se conduire à savoir
que la vocation ni chaînes commerciales
et 13 du chic
le pur ans
il y à une chaîne qui fait une certaine
part de marché qui a envie d'avoir un
panel de présentateurs et d'artistes
pour ratisser large
le retour de sabatier et qu'elle fait
visible maintenant je ne sais pas s'il a
bien fait d'accepter
l'os est rien non mais revêtent a
peut-être d'autres choses à dire donc tu
trouverais normal qu'à la rentrée par
exemple on ne vise qu'à écouter on est
désolé sabatier était plus que vous ce
qui n'est pas le cas tout de suite les
deuxièmement
il faut savoir le lot le lot d'un
artiste si je suis un artiste c'est la
certitude ouais je vais pas signer un
contrat à vie avec une chaîne
j'ai envie de tenter l'expérience parce
que j'aime bien mais tu as pris le
risque a réussi c'est bien ça m'a fait
plaisir sur le moment ça me faisait
plaisir qu'avec une équipe que j'aimais
bien et puis maintenant
aujourd'hui j'ai pas du tout envie
vous pensez des questions vraiment le
scan très curieux et le retournement des
stratégies commerciales même de tf1
reprend d'une autre chaîne dans le cul
rend ses caractéristiques c'est à dire
que effectivement au mois de juillet
1987 les rats quittent le navire way et
à sang la terreur faisait des paris en
toute beauté en toute loyauté oui et à
ce moment là jean luc a été contacté une
petite émission est né sur un concept
neuf
et ce qui est un peu
pas désolant de voir qu'aujourd'hui ces
concepts qui dit bonne la création et la
créativité des neuf à ce moment là et
ont joué la carte de la loyauté prêts
sont en compétition
du fait d'un monopole commercial
recouvrez avec uniquement des émissions
de jeux ou de variétés passe-partout
fouet et que la singularité à la fois
des choix initiaux et aussi de l'avenir
de l'activité senoglu des chaînes
kamerzin retrouve
remis en cause et ça va se retourner va
semblablement contre terre à la joie que
certains en sont conscients et qu'ils
essaient déjà de données ou jean-luc
sénat quant à proposer notre équipe et
du dimanche après midi parce qu'ils ont
des problèmes si le dimanche après midi
elle c'est vrai quand a demandé de vider
le dimanche après midi comme l'a pas
demandé
etienne mougeotte m'a parlé en substance
comme ça de la rentrée car je pense
qu'il était un
as
quelque part envie que je reste sur la
chaîne
et m'a parlé d'un mois tout le monde du
dimanche après midi parce que ça nous
arrangerait ce à quoi j'ai répondu
pourquoi pas la mire la météo
on voit difficilement demander à des
épaules dynamique que d'accepter d'avoir
le rôle de ventre mou ouais
est ce que tu crois pas que tu as un peu
victime de l'opposition qui entrent pas
publics et puis le trio bougeotte les du
toit se teinter plutôt copains du papier
comme maintenant j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour monsieur bouygues
beaucoup pour des raisons diverses ouais
pour la manière dont il a
il a il a maintenu son cap la manière
dont il a réussi sa vie ni son
raisonnement tu me plais beaucoup et
cette espèce de sensibilité pour les
gens
déjà en difficulté
s'intéresse aux choses et j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour monsieur oui c'est vrai
quoi qu'il arrive je viendrai l'image
d'un type formidable
je dois dire que les seuls rapports seul
conversations humaines entre guillemets
josy simplement avec monsieur wilson qui
s'est beaucoup de gens disent ah c'est
beau ça que j'en parle maintenant
etienne mougeotte je connais depuis de
nombreuses années un homme d'affaires
quant à monsieur le lait je les ai vus
nous avons parlé essentiellement
d'enfants jouets nous a
priori on n'a pas eu ni l'un ni l'autre
en vie nous on n'a pas trouvé le temps
de parler d'autre chose mais je ne crois
pas avoir été victime du tout ce qu'une
victime est une victime c'est quelqu'un
une victime c'est quoi si on oublait
larousse c'est tout sauf toi oui de
toute façon ne sais quoi la victime
c'est celle qui peut prétendre d'un
grave préjudice
parmi les cas donc pour le moment ça na
kwa pas du tout hervé en parlant de
contrat pour conclure et ce qui est un
bon débit en contractant les lacets
couverts par cette agression elle
on va regarder la chanson jean-luc n'est
pas homme à se dédire de manière
générale en mai sur le délit c'est bien
d'avoir un édit quand même
j'attends pas ça dépend de son
initiative